e aí
e eram 6 horas da manhã quando eu
cheguei na tv para trabalhar e me
deparei com inúmeras mensagens as minhas
redes sociais mensagens que lembravam de
um crime que tinha acontecido na minha
cidade um crime bárbaro uma criança de
apenas 11 anos foi morta e abusada
sexualmente enquanto brincava na rua as
mensagens que vinham nas caixas de
mensagem mesmo das redes sociais não
eram publicadas nos feeds ela dizia que
a polícia já tinham suspeito já tinha
encontrado o autor do crime e a mensagem
deixava muito claro foi ele tinha foto
do homem o nome desse homem e também o
bairro onde ele morava quando eu vi
essas mensagens na hora eu fiquei até
desesperado falei meu deus eu já
imaginei o que isso poderia causar na
vida desse homem que estava sendo
acusado de ter matado e abusado
sexualmente de uma menina de apenas 11
anos imediatamente liguei para o
delegado
há cerca de 20 minutos mais ou menos
para entrar ao vivo em gente estadual e
falar para as pessoas sobre essa notícia
porque todos os dias de manhã a gente
atualizar o caso porque é um caso de
muita repercussão inclusive repercussão
nacional quando eu liguei para o
delegado passei as informações que
estavam ali naquele naquele texto
naquela mensagem passei o nome do
suspeito que as pessoas falavam que a
polícia já tinha identificado passeio
todos os dados dele ali o delegado na
hora falou para mim que fábio nós não
estamos investigando esse homem ele não
é suspeito de nenhum crime não sei nem
de quem se trata nós temos dois
suspeitos mas nenhum desses dois
suspeitos é esse homem que você está me
falando na hora eu desliguei o telefone
agradecer o delegado e eu tinha ali uns
três quatro minutos somente para entrar
ao vivo em rede estadual e dá notícia
para todo o estado
ah e assim eu fiz falei para as pessoas
que aquela mensagem que estava
circulando nas redes sociais não era a
verdadeira era mentira esse homem não
era investigado pela polícia o delegado
não sabia nem quem ele era e aí pobre
jornalista achando que conseguiria
vencer a velocidade da internet vem ser
a velocidade dos clipes era tarde demais
as pessoas do bairro já tinha um
localizado o suspeito que já fizeram
justiça com as próprias mãos isso mesmo
fizeram justiça com as próprias mãos o
homem foi morto e depois de dois dias a
polícia conseguiu fazer as uma ação do
cadáver foi feito confronto genético e
chegaram à conclusão de que esse homem
não era o responsável pela morte da
menina ou seja dela inocente e foi morto
de forma brutal pelos moradores do
bairro da cidade onde eu vivo conseguem
perceber
e o perigo de uma notícia falsa
é uma pessoa foi morta e a justamente
isso que as fêmeas fazem elas tiram
vidas tiram direitos destroem sonhos e
até mesmo enfraquece a democracia e é o
que está acontecendo em todo mundo as
notícias falsas elas são criadas
geralmente para testar destruir uma
imagem para tentar destruir uma pessoa
mesmo ou até mesmo uma corporação e
quando ela se espalham elas conseguem
atingir seu objetivo elas conseguem
fazer isso o mundo inteiro hoje vive uma
crise das fake news nós recebemos
diariamente mensagens que são falsas mas
a gente precisa avaliar melhor esse
material e saber se a gente pode
compartilhar ou não mundo inteiro está
sofrendo com isso nos estados unidos até
mesmo presidente do país donald trump
está sendo acusado de espalhar notícias
falsas sobre o novo coronavírus
o acusado de tentar enfraquecer a doença
o poder devastador da doença aqui no
brasil não é diferente nós conseguimos
criar dentro da crise do novo
coronavírus uma crise política e também
a crise das fake news políticos estão se
desgastando perdendo energia para tentar
se defender de fake news ou até mesmo
para criar notícias falsas para tentar
que usar outros políticos também
enquanto deveriam estar gastando energia
para defender a população sobre essa
pandemia na câmara está sendo discutido
um projeto de lei que pune os autores de
fake news mas ao mesmo tempo isso pode
punir também o nosso direito de se
expressar nas redes sociais dá para
perceber o perigo que é uma fake news
enquanto o mundo inteiro discutir o
assunto aqui no país os políticos estão
brigando diariamente por causa das
tecnews
o grupo tenta atacar nos jornalistas
eles tentam fazer você acreditar que o
jornalismo de verdade o jornalismo que
apura as informações não fala a verdade
e sim essas fake news que circulam por
aí estão falando a verdade agora a gente
tenta sempre pensar nós como jornalistas
qual o motivo o que querem enfraquecer a
imprensa qual a razão disso tudo a gente
sabe que um país que não tem uma empresa
que cobra e fiscaliza que busca
informação precisa
eu não precisaria de um presidente de um
governador era só tem um ditador todo
mundo ele se pronunciaria todo mundo ir
lá falar ia nem para ele porque ele
disse mas não estão tentando fazer você
acreditar que nós jornalistas não
estamos falando a verdade e que essas
fake news inclusive que estão circulando
por aí a respeito da imprensa estão
falando a verdade sobre o que acontece
nos bastidores do jornalismo então era
justamente isso que eu queria que vocês
avaliassem melhor muitos vamos falar mas
eu compartilhei porque eu não sabia que
era fake news sabia sim a gente sabe
quando a notícia falsa se você abrir um
link recebe a mensagem os ele é uma
notícia bombástica geralmente que ela
precisa ser forte para conseguir fazer
com que as pessoas compartilhem aquele
material se você abre o texto confere dá
um google verifica-se outros veículos
estão falando sobre aquilo você não tem
nenhum veículo falar
a notícia falsa qual notícia é tão
importante que nem um outro jornalista e
atrás para tentar checar confirmar e
levar para a sociedade então é isso que
eu queria que vocês avaliassem melhor
pensar assim melhor antes de
compartilhar uma notícia as fake news já
fizeram a gente acreditar a gente entre
aspas porque nem todo mundo acreditou
que a vacina não serve para nada que vá
se não tem comprovação científica
nenhuma muitos pais inclusive deixaram
de vacinar seus filhos porque
acreditaram nessa mentira crianças
morreram por causa disso então você
consegue imaginar o poder de uma notícia
falsa o mais interessante é que as
mesmas pessoas que compartilharam as
fake news da vacina falando que não
tinha comprovação científica nenhuma
hoje compartilhem seus filhos de notícia
as mensagens meu deus
o que vai ter a vacina para o novo
coronavírus eu lembro porque eu lembro
de algumas pessoas que compartilharam
fake news da vacina e hoje estão
escrevendo isso nas redes sociais agora
dá para entender se você não acreditava
na vacina se ela não tinha comprovação
científica você compartilhou isso da sua
rede social porque que agora você tá
preocupado com uma notícia da vacina do
novo coronavírus então a gente tem que
sempre avaliar o que que a gente tá
falando nas redes sociais e que a gente
tá compartilhando o que que a gente tá
fazendo as pessoas acreditarem às vezes
você manda para sua mãe sua mãe mandar
para mais um esse mais uma dá para nós
dois e a gente cria uma rede e um ciclo
de notícias falsas e as notícias falsas
elas só existem porque a gente consome é
o mesmo caso dos furtos e roubos só
existem ou poderiam ser muito menores
que as pessoas não comprassem produtos
sem nota fiscal de origem duvidosa então
nós alimentamos essa indústria que
movimenta milhões de reais todos os anos
oi e aí eu queria que você só se
relembrar se naquele caso que eu contei
no início da nossa conversa aqui do
senhor que foi morto injustamente porque
compartilhar uma notícia falsa contra
ele e depois da polícia comprovou que
ele não era o autor do crime que que
você lembrasse desse caso para você
entender o poder de uma notícia falsa
talvez você não tenha compartilhado essa
notícia talvez você não tenha feito
parte dessa morte mas pare e pense
quantas notícias falsas você pode ter
compartilhado para sua vida quantos
cliques você pode ter dado e destruindo
pessoas